could you imagine sexting with chat GPT
that's what people are that's what
they're doing dude I mean at least like
at least you know that shot gbt when you
people call sex lines it's like you
don't know who you're talking to you
know what I mean literally yeah it could
be some dude oh they'll be able to do
like some with all the stuff they're
doing with the voice they'll be able to
do that we just call a number and just
speak to someone you don't even realize
you're speaking to some like uh Drake
yeah or whatever I
met a woman yeah a woman a woman yeah I
was just I've been playing a lot of
video games the last 40 years of my life
um but I've been here let's talk about
your profession I've been so deeply in
it the last year I just the last week
and a half I've been out of it I've been
working out and running and walking and
it's a different reality Ryan dude it's
like it is like sports no it's real 40
years you're like what is reality have
you guys ever tried walking
for the first time I think you guys that
was fake news I think they brought him
back